[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur le journal de
tv 78 nous sommes le mardi 11 février
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
locale et des actions pour sensibiliser
à la gestion des déchets sur la voie
publique depuis un an la ville des
clayes sous bois et mobiliser contre les
incivilités en tous genres et des
poubelles be fluent et des cendriers ont
été par exemple installé dans la commune
en février l'université versailles saint
quentin organise ses journées portes
ouvertes plus fr de santé simone veil à
montigny le bretonneux a reçu les
lycéens sous fond de réforme fin du
numerus clausus et de la première année
commune pour les études de médecine
explications et puis la page consacrée
aux élections municipales enfin
d'édition à saint-cyr-l'ecole une autre
liste s'est déclaré face à la maire
sortante saint cyr l'école en commun
sera conduite par lydie du long pont une
candidature sans étiquette et dans ce
journal
à suivre la fête des amoureux on vous
parle de la saint valentin on vous
propose pour cette fête d'embrasser les
arbres rester avec nous pour voir de
quoi il s'agit il y un an la ville des
clayes-sous-bois lancé une vaste
campagne de lutte contre les incivilités
après le respect des espaces publics et
le marquage au sol pour lutter contre
les déjections canines c'est le tri des
déchets qui y est concerné plusieurs
équipements ont été installés on voit ça
avec mélanie poker plus de déchets dans
la nature et plus d'erreurs de tri
possible au frais sous bois le parc de
diane est depuis plusieurs mois équipés
de poubelles be fluent c'est tout
simplement des poubelles s'ils voulaient
où on peut vous avez un côté de la
poubelle vous avez un côté gris c'est
plutôt ordures ménagères résiduelles et
vous avez un côté jaune avec sky rossi
clap c'est à dire les canettes le carton
le papier depuis un an la ville
multiplie les actions contre les
incivilités et la gestion des déchets
lors d'une action qui 9 d les
volontaires avaient ramassé plus de 170
kg de déchets dernière équipements
installer des cendriers scellés au sol
ou en hauteur ces mégots ensuite sont
traités vont être on va récupérer le
plastique à l'intérieur des fils
et qui va ensuite servir à fabriquer des
meubles du matériel de bureau des
crayons de pots à crayons
on n'est pas dans l'interdiction n'est
dans la dans la prévention
et c'est avec cet esprit là qu'on a
essayé d'aborder toutes ces questions-là
23 cendriers ont pris place dans
plusieurs lieux de la commune
certains seront amovible et prêté lors
de manifestations un simple geste grâce
auquel les mégots au sol seront des
vestiges fin du numerus clausus et
abolition de la première année commune
aux études de médecine voici les
principaux changements que connaîtront
les étudiants intéressés par ce parcours
lors de la prochaine rentrée
universitaire a dévoilé par le
gouvernement il ya plusieurs semaines
cette réforme vise à diversifier les
profils des étudiants et décloisonner
les filières de santé on en parle avec
loïc josseran bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le vice doyen de l'ufr de santé simone
veil de l'université versailles saint
quentin alors une réforme on va le voir
dans ce reportage tourné par et nicolas
kirilow vite ce qui est une source
d'angoissé pour les lycéens et aussi
leurs parents regardez ce reportage
réalisé lors des journées portes
ouvertes à l'ubs est ce qu les épreuves
du baccalauréat ne débuteront que dans 5
mois pourtant l'entrée à l'université
déjà un sujet de préoccupation pour ces
lycées
utile quand t'es pas structuré vraiment
quand a pas de méthode de travail etc tu
voues rythme après pas c'est vraiment
bien l'objet principal de leur réflexion
la réforme de la première année commune
aux études de médecine
aussi appelée paces elle s'ouvrir à
partir de septembre prochain à de
nouveaux profils
les étudiants avec avec une un tropisme
plus littéraire eux ont intérêt à passer
par des licences de droits des licence
d'histoire qui vont leur permettre
d'accéder à la deuxième année ça restera
néanmoins compétitif
concrètement depuis fin janvier sur
parcours sup les étudiants peuvent
choisir entre deux voies d'accès aux
études de médecine
la première permet de suivre par exemple
une licence d'économie de droit ou de
svt avec une option santé
la seconde plus classique donne la
priorité un parcours santé avec cette
fois ci une option d'une autre
discipline une réforme d'ampleur qui
suscite forcément de nombreuses
interrogations chez les futurs étudiants
et les parents ce nom mais il ya des
trucs qui apparaissent pas su alors j'ai
pas trouvé sur parcours sur les français
savent être énormément de stress parce
qu'entre les doublants sais pas combien
de places on va avoir en plus c'est que
les différentes mineurs et majeurs le
nombre de places dans chaque filière
finalement on vient d'être réduit dans
ce qu'on peut faire
donc oui ça peut rajouter france ou part
de stress assez important elle veut
rentrer 1 école de kiné il ya clairement
il ya eu un vide sidéral au niveau de
l'information
depuis la réforme on a eu des infos le
21 janvier en fait dernier et c'est
parce que j'ai fait la démarche de
chercher sur internet pour guider les
étudiants l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines a également
organisé une conférence sur le sujet
prochaine journée portes ouvertes le
samedi 29 février à la faculté de droit
et de sciences politiques
mais pour retrouver le programme complet
des journées portes ouvertes à lui vs qu
rendez vous sur le site internet de
l'université
le dos rond on vous a vu dans ce sujet
notre journaliste sur place a constaté
vous vous l'avez vu beaucoup de stress
parmi les lycéens présents leurs parents
également est ce que vous l'avez
également ressenti vous pendant ces sept
journées portes ouvertes à cette journée
a été une particulière par rapport aux
années antérieures effectivement
probablement parce que la réforme est
arrivée elle est là donc l'année
prochaine prochaine rentrée la réforme
est donc effectivement les parents sont
stressés les étudier futurs étudiants
sont également stressé puisque le
système est totalement nouveau
certainement très déboussolant puisque
habituellement c'était bien connu c'est
la paces le concours à la fin de l'année
là cette fois ci ces deux modes d'accès
en fonction probablement des capacités
des étudiants et des intérêts des
étudiants parce que le fou ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que cette réforme va amener
un continuum dans les ai tuées et
contrairement à ce qui était la paces où
effectivement si ça fonctionne et si on
réussit le concours alors tout allait
bien en passer en 2e année c'est en
revanche pour ceux qui échouent et
c'était plus compliqué puisqu'il avait
l'impression d'avoir perdu deux ans la
la la réforme va permettre aux étudiants
d'être dans une marche en avant
finalement à partir du moment où ils
réussissent leurs examens
ils seront dans une marche en avant qui
leur permettra de passer en 1ère 2ème
année alors peut-être pas de santé mais
dans ce qui a été dit dans le reportage
effectivement dans démineurs qui vont
choisir en droit en sciences en kiné
mais qui leur permettront non plus
d'heureux de rester scotché à un niveau
juste de post bac mais au contraire
d'avancé de passer progressivement elle
est d'avoir des profils aussi et
finalement plus diversifiées au sein de
ces études voir des profils diversifiés
c'est au fil c'est effectivement ce que
va permettre la réforme puisque là
aujourd'hui on
ce qu'on voit dans les résultats de
paces et qui se confirme d'année en
année c'est que les étudiants si c'est
pas un bac s avec une mention c'est plus
compliqué là les voies d'accès
différentes qui vont permettre de
passages parlés par droits qui vont
permettre des passages par par
l'histoire par aves économie et social
par éco gestion vont permettre une
diversification des profils et donc in
fine et des médecins différents des
pharmaciens différent peut-être avec un
peu plus d'humanité comme on l'espère
tous
on a entendu beaucoup de stress un parmi
les lycéens les parents est ce que aussi
du côté du ps qu il a fallu se
réorganiser en vue de cette réforme est
de cette réforme vous l'avez dit qu'il
va s'appliquer là dès la rentrée
prochaine si les parents et les
étudiants sont stressés les enseignants
le sont aussi
puisque c'est effectivement une réforme
majeure qui modifie radicalement
l'organisation de notre université mais
vraiment complètement puisque ça impacte
aussi bien l'ufr de médecine de santé
que lui affaire de droits mais également
l'ufr de sciences puisqu'elles vont
devoir est légale elle aussi pardon
portée des mineurs santé donc permettre
à leurs étudiants de suivre un
enseignement de santé pour ceux qui
veulent se passer ensuite erré intégrer
une filière santé non plus de
collaboration il y en avait des gens on
imagine mais plus de collaboration des
différents su à travers tout à fait les
sept formations de santé va être
complètement transversale et va donc
intéresser aussi bien des étudiants qui
sont en droit qui sont en sciences qui
sont en rsa que des étudiants qui sont
en santé et à linverse le droit va
intéresser des étudiants qui sont en
droit mais aussi qui sont dès qu'ils
sont en santé et si on regarde ces deux
parcours on va pouvoir revoir
l'animation s'afficher la voici il ya
donc deux parcours vous l'avez dit un
plus classique parcours axé santé
complété d'une autre option pourra faire
quoi concrètement c'est désolant vert
donc là les laisser les trois options
que nous mettons au choix des étudiants
vont porter soit sur la saluer faire des
sciences donc récupérer une filière
cents soit une mineure droit pour
récupérer ensuite si si si les étudiants
ne sont pas reçus en santé va récupérer
une filière droit d'une nouvelle de ce
droit tout simplement ou encore et ça
c'est une particularité pour nous et
c'est une expérimentation au niveau
national que nous menons sur lui à faire
de santé a lui exclu la possibilité de
rentrer ensuite directement à elles deux
kinés donc nous mettrons en place une
mineure alors pas exactement qui n'est
rééducation réadaptation qui amènera au
mit aux métiers de la rééducation
réadaptation tels que kiné argot
thérapeute psychomotricien ou pédicure
podologue
donc ça c'est une particularité que nous
avons est donc l'autre voie possible
c'est de faire finalement une licence
dans une autre filière tout en suivant
une option accès santé cette option
concrètement on y fera quoi
dans cette option accès santé donc
l'option santé ça sera 80 heures qui
tous les étudiants suivront alors en
plus c'est 80 heures il y aura un module
spécifique pour la prendre pour la
découverte des métiers de la santé
puisqu'il a énormément de métier
derrière le sol à la notion de santé
donc une découverte des métiers de santé
de façon à ce que les étudiants
s'oriente convenablement et puis
également une formation la préparation
des examens puisqu'il va y avoir et ça
aussi c'est une nouveauté dans la
réforme d or aux précédents cédant se
dansait dans ce nouvel examen puis ça
s'appelle plus un concours mais un
examen
néanmoins ça restera compétitif et un
autre nombre de places sera limité donc
nous devrions y aura des passerelles
possibles mais ça restera quand même
compliqué ça restera quand même un
concours
même si le terme n'apparaît plus
aujourd'hui dans le lot dans la réforme
néant
- le nombre de places est limité donc
seuls les premiers pourront être pris
effectivement mais avec un mur avec un
numerus clausus même si le terme n'est
plus d'actualité qui sera lui aussi
élargi donc il y aura plus étudiants
mais avec cette cette particularité
c'est l'introduction d'un oral human de
2 euros puisque les étudiants passeront
devant deux jurys différents pour que
les chances soient soient convenablement
équitable voilà compris avec des options
qui permettront pourquoi pas de se
réorienter si nécessaire si nécessaire
on serions en droit en sciences ou on
file vers une filière de rééducation et
réadaptation comme kiné par exemple je
rappelle cette date 12 mars un fin de la
saisie des voeux sur la plateforme
parcours super si loïc josseran est
d'être venu décrypter tout ça pour nous
en plateau vice doyen de l'ufr de santé
simone veil de l'ue vs qu on retrouve
toutes les informations sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
c'est un rendez-vous bien installée à
versailles samedi le tournoi is porte et
est organisé pour la troisième fois dans
la cité royale une après midi où 200
passionnés se sont retrouvés pour
s'affronter sur écran interposé allez on
prend sa manette ça sourit et son
clavier avec mélanie poké déplace prisé
et un public qui répond présent la
troisième édition du tournoi is pente a
de nouveau fait le plein ce week-end
plus de 200 joueurs se sont affrontés
durant tout un après-midi amateurs comme
professionnels
le bilan c'est que gp2 dû m'adapter
j'ai vu mon niveau et ça m'a fait
plaisir le but c'était de jouer très
content parce que je pensais pas passer
le premier tour final j'ai passé assez
facilement j'ai sorti premier de la
poule
du coup fier de moi quand même je vais
très très jeune on a besoin d'eux entre
guillemets agrandir la communauté est
donc là ça me permet de rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes et puis de jouer
avec des joueurs que j'affectionne
après deux saisons tourner autour de
leurs stone tournoi s'est ouvert à deux
nouveaux jeux du football avec fifa 20
et league of legends le numéro un du
monde de l'esport qui vient de fêter ses
10 ans
[Musique]
l'idée c'était que les jeux c'est un peu
comme des disciplines sportives on a
beau être sportif si on joue pas au
rugby on va pas forcément sur le rugby
donc là l'idée c'était d'avoir plus de
diversité plus de personnes qui étaient
intéressés mais pas forcément sur un
seul jeu donc là ça a permis d'avoir des
communautés trois joueurs qu'on peut
imaginer qu'il y en aura plus de 4 et
les vainqueurs se sont partagé près de
4000 euros de dotation les équipements
déjà à une quatrième édition
nj - 3 avant la saint-valentin et si
vous n'avez pas d'idée justement une
idée originale un week-end romantique à
beaune l2 sylvo terapeak est organisé le
principe de cet art japonais éveiller
ses sens en se reconnectant aux arbres
le reportage de nos cupidon préféré
michaël et demi d'euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude vous allez chercher
et trouver un on va dire un bateau
environ 20 30 cm qui qui vous plaît
alesis chercher le se reconnecter à la
forie à son environnement pour fêter la
saint valentin c'est l'une des promesses
de cet établissement situé sur la
commune de bonnel à deux pas de la forêt
de rambouillet aujourd'hui isabelle
teste son coin avant de recevoir les
couples pour la fête des amoureux
objectif le bien-être on est souvent
déconnecté par notre travail par le fait
d'habiter au 20ème étage le fait d'être
en ville on est déconnecté de la nature
et c'est vrai que pour être bien pour
gérer son stress
on peut aller dans la nature et profiter
notamment des arbres avec les terpènes
et puis ton side et tous les bienfaits
qu'ils ont naturellement pendant le
cours d'une heure et demie plusieurs
ateliers sont proposés pour éveiller les
sens avec ces différents éléments
ça va être de mettre en avant la mouche
des arbres ou même par terre donc ça
peut être en fait faire ressortir comme
ça et là on voit l'arbre mais on voit
aussi le papillon le moment fort de la
session la reconnexion osa dans l'est
touchant pendant plusieurs minutes pour
ressentir
la vie la sève qui passe quelque part
c'est aussi un moment d'introspection
parce qu'on peut tout à fait confier une
joie une peine à voir une question et
c'est un moment d'ouverture d'esprit
à la fin de la session première réaction
c'est une expérience vraiment inédite et
ressourçante je pense en rapport avec le
monde de demain vers la nature c'est pas
du tout conventionnelle c'est très
naturel très très différent de
de ce qui peut être très connu voilà
donc c'est c'est une expérience qui est
très sympa à faire si vous êtes moins
terre-à-terre l'établissement compte
également 73 champ mais d'autres
activités dont les ateliers yoga pour
profiter de ce week-end de
saint-valentin il faudra débourser 420
euros pour une chambre double deuxième
partie de ce journal consacré aux
élections municipales à plaisir d'abord
patrick jean terre et les membres de sa
liste plaisir notre ville notre avenir
ont organisé une rencontre en fin de
semaine dernière c'était à la salle des
fêtes des gâtines une réunion publique
pour présenter son équipe son programme
et échanger avec les habitants
nicolas landry être à l'écouté des
plaisirs wa faire participer les
citoyens aux décisions de la
municipalité le pilier du programme de
patrick jean terre et de sa liste
plaisir notre ville notre avenir
plusieurs propositions comme la création
d'un conseil municipal des jeunes ou la
mise en place de conseils de quartier
entre les habitants et les élus
municipaux
ces conseils de quartier seront agrégés
sur ce que nous allons appeler un
conseil
le développement participatif mesirow
avec lee nous réfléchirons sur des
sujets stratégiques à très long terme la
ville de demain
le pmu lan local d'urbanisme pour 2022
le plan local de déplacement le plan
d'alimentation territoriales dans cette
liste des personnes d'expérience ex
membre de la majorité actuelle puis des
citoyens souhaitant s'engager pour la
commune ce qui m'a vraiment séduit c'est
ce projet d'avoir une équipe plurielle
qui à la fois à semblent différentes
sensibilités différentes compétences et
qui puisse servir un projet qui
ressemble un peu à l'image de plaisir
avec ce tout se mélange d'énergie
positif en rencontrant les habitants
patrick jr et son équipe ont identifié
cette thématique environnement santé
sécurité entre autres des priorités avec
déjà des mesures concrètes et des
objectifs de manière à mieux gérer notre
d'émissions carbone pour l'amener à zéro
d'ici 2050 pour la baisser de 20% sur le
mandat pour investir 20 km de pistes
cyclables avant la fin du mandat
c'est entre autres quelques exemples sur
les axes sur lesquels nous allons
travailler d'autres propositions comme
la mise en place de navettes
interquartiers la volonté d'attirer au
moins dix médecins sur la commune avant
2026 la possibilité de recourir au
référendum pour décider de certains
projets à rambouillet ils sont cinq
candidats déclarés pour le moment pour
ces élections municipales le conseiller
municipal d'opposition à david jutier
pour europe ecologie les verts et gilles
schmitt suppléant de la députée des
yvelines
aurore bergé qui a le soutien de la
république en marche trois autres listes
seront également sur cette campagne des
municipales une campagne à rambouillet à
1 largement centrée sur l'écologie et le
cadre de vie véronique matillon conduira
la liste divers droite est de la
majorité sortante rambouillet ensemble
vers l'avenir elle prend la suite de
marc robert maire sortant qui ne se
représentera pas l actuelle adjointe
souhaite redynamiser les commerces re
végétalisation des quartiers
préservation des terres agricoles font
également partie de ses priorités
la liste rambouillet à gauche vivante et
solidaire sera conduite par jean-marc
seiler membres du collectif progressiste
de la ville il a été maire adjoint
pendant 13 ans de clamart dans les
hauts-de-seine avant de venir habiter le
sud yvelines dans son programme trois
axes démocratie participative emploi et
écologie enfin lui siège dans
l'opposition municipale rambo liten et
aussi au conseil régional d'île de
france philippe chevrier est également
candidat à la mairie l'ex secrétaire
départemental du front national et
fondateur du front libéré est à la tête
de ce top aux taxes à rambouillet il
veut mettre fin à l'augmentation de la
fiscalité locale et créer un marché
couvert toute l'actualité des élections
municipales à retrouver également ce
soir dans l'émission 7 8 politique
présentée par wilfrid wilfried richy sur
tv 78 à saint cyr l'école pour le moment
deux listes qui se profile un duel à
deux qui se profile
on parle de ces élections municipales
dans la ville avec l idi du long pont
bonsoir vous êtes la tête de liste de
saint-cyr-l'ecole en commun c'est une
candidature qui se veut ouverte et
citoyenne le choix de vous comme tête de
liste a été dévoilée mercredi dernier
comment s'est fait ce choix justement au
sein de la liste ce chat a été réalisée
lors d'une élection sans candidat
où les membres du mouvement et du
porte-parole du mouvement pour les
représenter à travers des valeurs
d'indépendance politique nous ne sommes
surpris par aucun parti politique et des
valeurs d'humanisme d'écologie et de
transport et du coup pourquoi être
candidat que vous n'êtes pas issu de la
politique locale pourquoi vous lancer
dans cette démarche de politique locale
j'ai souhaité rejoindre le mouvement
saint cyr l'école en commun ça m'a paru
complètement logique en fait par rapport
à mes activités associatives ou l'idée
c'était de mettre en place des projets
pour la ville pour les habitants pour
qu'ils se sentent bien dans leur ville
et j'ai pu constater qu'il y avait une
certaine limite pour pouvoir mettre en
place des projets et et faire en sorte
que la ville soit juste sur la liste
vous l'avez dit elle se veut citoyenne
c'est à dire qu'elle est composée
d'habitants essentiellement il n'y a pas
de personnes qui ont été élus dans le
conseil municipal de saint cyr l'école
par exemple n'ont pas du tout en fait
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
saint cyriens depuis mois de septembre
sur le terrain et également nous avons
organisé trois grandes assemblées
participatives et où l'objectif c'était
de co construire le programme avec les
habitants et c'est ce qui a été fait
et se veut ouverte aussi il n'ya pas
d'appartenance politique pas de
revendiquer pas d'investiture
particulière non pas du tout c'est ça
fait pas du tout partie de notre valeur
c'est même quelque chose qui a été
rejeté par le mouvement donc c'était pas
du tout un souhait d'appartenir à une
et pourquoi pas su à l'échelle d'une
commune gérer une commune l'étiquette
politique importe peu finalement c'est
plutôt les idées le projet qui s'exalte
réponse ça n'avait pas de sens au niveau
local d'être du parent partie et c'est s
était pas une volonté alors vous serez
candidat de face et une autre femme
sonia breux qui est maire sortante de
saint cyr qui a succédé en cours de
mandat à bernard de bain qui a été lu de
lui depuis 2008 et qui a démissionné
l'an passé quel regard vous portez sur
le travail effectué sur certes cette
dernière mandature par la majorité
sortante
ce que j'ai pu constater ainsi qu'un
certain nombre de saint cyrien c'est
malheureusement l'augmentation de la
bétonisation c'est vraiment un discours
qui ressort tout le temps quand je
rencontre des saint cyriens et
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
travailler via le plan local d'urbanisme
donc c'est une ville qui a beaucoup
changé et sincères il ya une nouveau
quartier qui se sont construits pendant
ce mandat un peu une explosion
démographique et malheureusement les
infrastructures ne suivent pas donc
c'est une recherche de d'améliorer les
services publics aussi donc lutte contre
la bétonisation ça renvoie à l'une des
priorités en tout cas des axes
prioritaires de votre démarche
la transition écologique notamment
revégétaliser la ville ça ça fait partie
des des idées que vous avez dans ce
programme
oui tout à fait nous avons vraiment deux
grands piliers au sein du mouvement qui
sont la transition écologique et la
transition démocratique
donc on a l'intention de créer des
instances participatives pour permettre
aux habitants de prendre des décisions
et de sur les projets qui les
intéressent au sein de leur quartier
avec également la mise en place de
budget participatif et en ce qui
concerne la transition écologique un
gros retard à saint cyr l'école on peut
pas se permettre d'attendre encore six
ans pour démarrer la transition
écologique est effectivement reverdir la
ville c'est une priorité pour pouvoir
s'adapter au changement climatique qui
ça fait partie des idées ce qu'il y en a
d'autres en matière de transition
écologique
bien sûr il ya la sécurisation des
pistes cyclables par exemple pour que
les familles puissent oser faire du vélo
à saint cyr l'école
par exemple il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire sur sur la question de la
circulation a sorti à l'école il faut
vraiment qu'on travaille sur un schéma
de circulation différent avec un sujet à
suivre avec attention j'imagine c'est
l'arrivée du tram 13 express qui est
prévu dans les quelques prochaines
années à saint cyr qui reliera saint cyr
l'école à saint germain en laye oui tout
à fait c'est fait partie d'eads et s'axe
sur donc la démocratie participative
vous l'avez dit plusieurs idées budget
participatif par exemple ça ça peut être
l'une des pistes à à mettre en place
pour faire participer les citoyens les
habitants de saint cyr à la décision
comme elle a tout à fait en fait on a
constaté on a constaté ça en fait aux
saint cyr l'école un manque
d'implication des habitants enfin c'est
à dire qu'on a permis de prendre
certaines décisions c'est sûr ça peut
être sur le nom de la maison des
associations mais vraiment participer au
débat construire ensemble les choses
avec la municipalité c'est que ce n'est
pas du tout offert et d'ailleurs ça fait
partie des choses qu'on va mettre en
place et dès le début du mandat c'est
une demi heure de parole citoyenne
pendant le conseil municipal donc
démocratie participative transition
écologique y aussi un autre axe c'est de
recréer du lien social à saint cyr
l'école oui tout à fait je suis parti du
constat qu' il n'y avait pas du tout de
maisons de quartier à saint cyr l'école
et ses fins et c'est assez rare je
trouve dans les villes en tout cas que
j'ai fréquenté j'ai toujours vu des
maisons cartier et à saint cyr l'école
je pense que c'est très important de
recréer du lien interne
intergénérationnel entre les habitants
et ça passe par la création de lieux
comme des maisons de quartier un tiers
lieux voilà il ya plein de choses qui
n'existent pas à saint cyr l'école et
qui existe même dans les toutes petites
villes de province et par exemple
pourrait créer un fab lab en fait c'est
un atelier de fabrication qui
permettrait aux personnes de réparer
leurs objets par exemple une dernière
question vos prochaines réunions
publiques ça va être le jeudi 5 mars à
20 heures à la salle des fêtes de saint
cyr l'école on retrouve bien sûr en tous
les agents d'adp campagne des candidats
à ces élections municipales sur notre
site internet tv 78 points comme merci
lydie du long pont est d'être venu en
plateau et tête de liste de
saint-cyr-l'ecole en commun pour le
moment une autre liste en a qui sera
candidat de face à vous celle de sonia
broc maire sortante avec la liste saint
cyr au coeur 2020 et je rappelle
d'ailleurs avant de vous à l'issic à
l'occasion de cette campagne des
municipales tv 78 en association avec
radio sensations vous propose des débats
entre les candidats des bills yvelinois
ce soir c'est avec la commune de mort
pas un débat à retrouver à 20h sur tv 78
sur la fréquence également 98.4 pour
sensations et binou en replay sur tv
soixante dix huit points comme voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal restez avec
nous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants le 7-8 culture présentée par
aurélie ronde belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]